[موسيقى]
بالنسبة لنا Gruyère مهم
في ثقافتنا
كما أنها تمثل جزءًا من سويسرا
إذا أردت ، هناك جبال لها
الشوكولاته هناك الجبن ثم
Gruyère هو أحد الشباب
[موسيقى]
اسمي اسكندر يستحق
أنا مزارع أصنع رافعة
المراعي الجبلية امس
[موسيقى]
تم إنشاء الصفحة الربيعية فقط من مايو إلى
أكتوبر راند بينما ليل
ذاهب إلى الجبل وهذا كل شيء
الفرق مع Gruyère العادي الذي
يتم القيام به له طوال العام على ما أعتقد
الكثير من الأهمية بالنسبة لـ
جودة الجبن عائلتي
تنتج المراعي الجبلية المشوية منذ ذلك الحين
الآن خمسة أجيال
لذلك كان والدي هو من علمني ذلك
صنع مشاوي يلهث هو عليه
بطريقة تقليدية
لذلك كل شيء يتم بدون الأنابيب
لكن أعتقد أنه لعب دورًا في
طعم الجبن أيضا
عملية صنع جبن جروير
المراعي الجبلية تبدأ هناك الساعة 5 صباحًا
في الصباح عندما نذهب للبحث عن الأبقار
ثم نقوم بحلب يذهب الحليب
ثم مباشرة في الغلاية
في التحول هو جعل
تخثر الجبنة
ثم نقوم بتسخينه عند 56 درجة
التعويذة أو الضغط بعد الضغط
ضعه في حوض من الأملاح
24 ساعة ثم يتم إحضارها إلى
قشور في الجبن الصلب الناضج
حوالي ستة أشهر
ولكن بعد ذلك يمكننا أن نقول الجبن
ما يصل إلى عامين مختلفة
طرق أكل gruyere لكن أين أنا
الجزء الخاص بي هو أفضل طريقة أجد ذلك
إنه بقطعة جيدة من gruyere
بقطعة خبز حيث نحن
يشعر بطعم الجبن أفضل
استمرار هذا التقليد هي
مهم لأنه مرت سنوات على
الأسرة هو يفعل ذلك وأنا أجد ذلك
من الجيد الاستمرار في التقليد
هنا
[موسيقى]